[Music]
rain dampened a somber ceremony here in
New York City a moment of silence as a
wreath was laid in Madison Square Park
in honor of Veterans Day more than 20
thousand vets marched in New York's
parade later in the afternoon there are
more than 17 million American veterans
but just one percent of the 16 million
who served in World War II are still
alive David Martin introduces us to a
survivor of the Battle of the Bulge
who's in a class all his own
well I'm always glad to see another
Veterans Day to see this Veterans Day
herb Stern had to live to the age of
103.
and survived the bloodiest American
battle of World War II nineteen thousand
Americans killed yeah we lost a lot of
people I lost a lot due to the weather
too in the winter of 1944 Stern's
division had just crossed into Germany
when Hitler launched a last-ditch
counter-offensive which broke through
the American lines creating the Bulge
which gave the six-week battle its name
I've never been so cold in my life you
couldn't see you couldn't move a little
snow on the ground did you have winter
gear the Army was not prepared for this
weather we were ill-equipped we had no
bad weather boots about halfway through
the Battle of the Bulge they issued us
rubber galoshes which didn't do much
good really which was worse the weather
or the Germans
the weather
Hitler had caught the Americans by
surprise and was aiming to get into the
rear and cut off their supply lines how
close did the Germans ever come to your
position there was nothing but confusion
no one knew anyone else's location I
decided to walk down a road
and I walked down the couple hundred
yards and this Belgian woman
was running up the road waving screaming
Le Bush Les Bush the Germans yes
and uh so I decided I'd better get out
of there stern was an artillery officer
and his unit had just been issued shells
fitted with a new fuse this fuse would
set it off automatically 20 yards above
the ground
it was
deadly what made it so devastating use
it against troops in foxholes the burst
came 20 yards above you right into the
Foxhole in a really very little
protection against the burst he was a
Savage battle neither he nor any of his
fellow Cadets in the West Point class of
41 could have imagined when they
graduated on the eve of the greatest war
in human history
40 of them died in that war and time has
now taken the rest
herb Stern is the Last Man Standing I
miss a lot of my classmates yeah we were
a very close class since we you know
graduated right into the war for CBS
Saturday morning David Martin Sterling
Virginia
he's incredible he really and we thank
him we certainly do absolutely grateful
for their service